weighing as much as a ton each these
slabs are all that's left of an ancient
people arranged in circles the openings
face east these are the megawatts of sin
Gaia
massive stones in the sands of Senegal
moved here by hand by a mysterious
people
this man is determined to dig up some
answers
anthropologist Augustine Hall leads a
team of more than two dozen students
from the University of Michigan to help
solve the riddle of the stones they've
got their work cut out for them there
are about 2,000 sites including circles
and other markers spread over thousands
of square miles all of them standing
guard over human bones and there are
clues the way these bones were buried
was highly unusual Augustine's team of
detectives begin here circle number 27
unlike all the rest this one's a circle
within a circle Augustine believes this
ancient people didn't bury their dead
all at once but over a period of time
they would put the body in a shallow
grave and wait for the flesh to decay
then they would choose specific bones to
bury yet another ceremony a second step
involve in the process of selecting of a
body part which has to be now carried
maybe in a procession to the new burrow
ground and then buried in environment
the students are finding proof that this
theory just might be true so far they're
not finding whole skeletons only certain
parts mostly skulls
if there were two crania located here
and then one here and originally we
thought that it was a primary barrier
I'm going to full body but after we
exposed everything instead of removing
we realized that it followed the same
patterns as our other discoveries the
Skull and Bones fills the inner circle
but the outer circle contains a
different pattern ceramic pots on top of
Jawbone's
the pots may have held offerings for the
afterlife this explanation of multiple
burials for the dead goes against what
many people believe happened here there
will be some controversy and IV&V see
how science progresses for now Augustine
and his detectives will continue to pry
open these doorways to the dead for the
dead have taken the answers with them